hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome attacking game a lot of you have
been asking me to show a few games from
the
women's uh feeder grand prix in
gibraltar that happened a few days ago
and
this is the one that i chose the
tournament is already over and arjun's
abu malik won the tournament uh without
a single loss and
uh not only that she wanted to win the
tournament uh she won her grandmaster
title and that this
is one game i decided to show but if you
guys know of any great games uh from the
event to do
uh uh share it using hashtag suggestion
i will
uh i will go through it so here arjansa
faces antoinetta stefano a former
uh women's world champion from bulgaria
uh from 2006 to 2008
uh so uh while she was facing her she
was still an international master
always difficult when you're facing um
uh such an experienced grandmaster but
this game it's really a beauty uh
without further ado let's check it out
uh abdul malik opens with e4
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
now uh d4 yeah it's been a while since
we had a nice scotch game
uh we have e capture sunday for knight
captures and the now queen to f6
bishop to c5 is the most played move
here and then you can
of course combine it with queen to f6
queen to f6 a bit more
rare but uh still still played quite a
lot uh and here
knight to b3 now this is already very
rare bishop to e3
just guarding the knight while
developing a piece kind of is the
usual way people do it but knights the
b3 uh it will serve a very
very nice purpose as you'll see we have
queen to g6 a standard move when playing
against this setup putting pressure on
the g2 pawn attacking the e4 pawn
here uh defends it with f3 and now comes
bishop to d6 and here with this bishop
to d6 move you see that
black does not really have a good square
to develop this bishop
uh you want to develop this knight the
e7 so the bishop
obviously is not coming to e7 you can't
really bring it to c5
now the knight from b3 nicely defends
this and if you go bishop to b
for check well white will simply play
bishop to d2 and
you don't you don't really gain anything
by this or or even c3 is possible
uh but here we have bishop to b6 this is
what the black usually plays against
this setup knight to c3
and now comes knight g to e7 uh
here there is a trick that you you might
try bishop captures an h2 i know
a lot of you are interested in this
bishop captures an h2
uh rook captures in queen g3 check why
doesn't black just play this well it
doesn't work it doesn't work because
after the king moves obviously you have
to capture the rook otherwise you're
just going to be down too much material
uh knights the d5 comes and it seems
like
okay but the queen is guarding c7 there
is no threat here
but there is a really great threat and
uh well
bishop to f4 is coming there there's not
much you can do about it especially if
you play something like let's say play
knight to f6 97 you try to finish
development the bishop to f4 and it's
game over
there's no playing this the queen is
under attack or you're already
threatening this
and if queen to h4 trying to say okay if
you capture it then maybe i'm going to
be able to capture here
uh you can uh just play something like
knight captures here king moves and
queen to d6 guarding the bishop and it's
a
total annihilation there's no no playing
this for black so
while you could maybe you know play play
something better
uh it's definitely not suggested to play
something like this so here knight g to
e7 black just wants to finish
development
and now this position has been reached
before there were some moves uh
pawn to g4 is the most usual move that's
played here
but here we have f4 and it is now
already as of move eight that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how black deals with this
well you could just castle here uh black
decides to go bishop to b4 first
now the knight is pinned of course queen
captures on e4 is the threat
uh but so now just f5 uh pushing back
the queen
queen to f6 and now comes the bishop to
d3 so just continuing development may be
referring to castle here
and here you really have to uh
allow white to sacrifice upon
you really have nothing better other
than for example captures with
checkpoint captures queen captures and
now after bishop to d2 the queen now
guards the rook here
okay the the rook was already guarded
but still uh we're just gonna play the
queen back now white's gonna castle
and uh well black is very much behind in
development but
nothing uh nothing too serious is
happening uh
of course you have to be very careful
but uh you will be you will be able to
play this
however in the game black decided that
maybe it's a bit too much
going after the spawn we're already
behind on development so here bishop the
d6 was played
but now comes uh well now there will be
trouble
uh because here okay if white castles
then you
will probably go for some like queen h4
threat and this checkmating pattern with
bishop captures an h2 and if this then
we can just
sacrifice here and get a drawback
perpetual which for black maybe isn't
such a bad idea
uh for from this position however uh
chancellor plays queen to
h5 and now uh there is no more castling
because now if you castle
then you've allowed castles uh and now
that uh
well there's really not much you can do
against bishop to g5
for example if h6 you're just going to
play g4 now g5 is coming and
it's just uh unplayable position for
black whatever you play
let's say make a move g5 is coming h
captures we're gonna play bishop
captures
and after the queen moves uh you really
don't care uh there's no
queen captures here because the queen
covers the h2 square you're just gonna
play rook f3 rook h3
and you're going to checkmate the black
king if g6 you don't care
just f captures knight captures and now
for example knight to d5 because the
knight just moves this knight is coming
to f6 that's
i mean this is this game is over so
instead after this queen to h5
uh you really don't have a good move uh
a5 was played
because what else to play i mean nothing
is really happening
uh here we have castles by white and now
a4 and this is just a bit too much now
we don't really care about the knight
here we just play bishop to g5
uh we have queen to e5 and now bishop
back to f4 the rook from f1 guards the
bishop here
uh we have queen to f6 uh probably the
least painful uh move for black is just
to give up the queen here for
uh for a piece and the rook and say okay
maybe maybe i can hold this although you
really can't
uh this is the equivalent of resigning
uh queen back to f6 was played and
now e5 e5 is incredible
because the e5 square is covered three
times by black but uh
white doesn't care here we have bishop
captures an e5 and now
feel free to pause the video here and
win this game for white uh well i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that it's
a similar position from the one in the
thumbnail and
you should be able to find it and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
knight the e4 and this is just now crazy
all of these squares are taken away
from the black queen and you don't have
a move here so you could capture an f5
which is what happened in the game
but now now comes the good stuff knight
the d6 with check now we've reached the
position from the thumbnail
and basically if this was uh a game for
maybe uh from an event that's not so
important maybe we'd see a resigns here
but in the actual game we we saw a few
more moves so black capture 10 d6
we have bishop captures on f5 uh not
knight captures on f5 but first uh a
captures on b3 grabbing this knight
bishop captures an e5 knight captures an
e5 and now bishop to a4 so black will
still
attempt a few moves uh so pawn captures
an a2
you do have a pass pawn on a2 so it
might be possible to do something
but now queen d1 going after the d6 pawn
we have rook to a6 defending the pawn
and now bishop to d5 now getting rid of
the pass pawn
and once you eliminated this then black
really has nothing to play for
so here rook to a5 going after the
bishop just bishop captures an a2 we
have d5 now this is defended
but you don't care queen e1 attacks the
rook here we have
knight to c6 are now attacking the rook
also adding a little more protection to
this knight here
uh and now b4 and this is now the
cleanest way to in the game it's simply
beautiful
uh how abdul malik does it attacks the
rook rook to b5 and now
c3 adding another defender to the pawn
here and now preparing to end the game
because after castle was played just
queen to e2 attacking the rook and
that's it there's no way to defend the
rook you have to play rook to b6 and now
b5 and that's it it was in this position
and moved 28 that antoinette stefano
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the knight is under
attack you can't move it the pawn is
defended if you move the knight you lose
this knight
and then of course you will be
down simply too much material yeah like
i said
the game could have been resigned on
move 17 if it was maybe a less important
game but since it's a very important
game
i lasted a whole 28 moves but really an
impressive attacking game and it's been
a while since we've
seen a nice scotch mini scotch miniature
and it really just all went down to
black
prolonging castles but you it was never
really a good
good idea and even if you castled in the
position where it was okay
uh you would still allow white to have
uh to have a very nice attack but all in
all a great game and like i said uh john
cia
won the grand masters title she crossed
the 2500 elo
uh rating and uh well
won the tournament without without a
single loss these are the winners uh
let me just find it these are the
winners uh abdul malik in in the middle
uh maria muzuchuk on the left and uh uh
majada on the uh on the right scoring uh
third place so very very nicely done
congratulations
on the world's newest grand master and
uh hope we see many more games like this
i've checked out some of her other games
she's a
very aggressive player plays a very
interesting chess very
very much attacking chess so if you guys
want to see some more games do
uh share in the comment section below
and like i said if you want to see any
other games from the event do use
hashtag suggestion
and we're going to go through all of
your suggestions
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
caihan gulteken uh evgeny brishkin mario
gooda mark london and jeffrey turner for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day